for the second year in a row as part of
the New York Comedy Festival we're
taking our show on the road to New York
City looking forward to that there we go
that's right we will once again be doing
shows at the historic Apollo Theater in
Harlem from November 6th through the 9th
they already have me up on the marquee
which seems immature yeah I think that's
an artist rendering anyway we have some
incredible guests lined up we'll be
announcing them in the next couple of
weeks also if you'd like to come see one
of our New York City shows in person
just head to team koco.com slash tickets
for information be sure to tune in you
will not want to miss those New York
shows oh yeah that's so awesome
okay that said that's one of our
cameramen Tony Tony what's up so you're
taking the show to New York that's
that's right Tony yeah hey Conan guess
where I'm from New York yeah that's uh
that's really great Tony really huge
Apple
excuse me they're huge Apple that's one
of the nicknames in New York I know a
lot about New York yeah okay I'm pretty
sure it's the Big Apple
not a huge Apple says you I grew up
there and I know everything about the
city where you're almost definitely
awake it's the city that never sleeps
Tony Tony
where exactly in New York did you grow
up in lizard beach lizard beach yeah
it's a small neighborhood in between
cheese village and purple wood I grew up
in a one-room duplex across the street
from the Museum of escalators oh the
Museum of escalators I'd love to check
the Museum of escalators doesn't exist
this is ridiculous
doesn't exist anymore they knocked it
down to put in an Abercrombie and Fitch
and Arby's the whole place smells like
Cologne and roast beef okay you know
what Tony I'm pretty sure you're making
all this stuff up all right you'll be in
such a Cassandra
Kassandra yeah from that popular new
york-based show sex on top of the city
Sandra was the lesbian eye doctor who
wrote a newspaper column about sex on
rooftops man Tony I love that like I
said I'm sorry we'll be doing our show
from the Apollo Theater of the week of
November 6th good luck Conan is like
they say if you can make it there Wow
good for you that's a before really hard
place to me
[Applause]
you